look at it sooner or later long over the
Windler rookie steps in that's back five
four welcome John Elmore out of Marshall
handling the ball now streets with
another three-point opportunity and
that's off the court then doesn't take
much to jam that home when you're seven
six here this afternoon there's no doubt
about a taco fall standing and delivery
it's Boston by 13
this kid is doing a good job behind the
way he's past shoot it and it's over all
nod to know how to play green up top to
fall these kids have cable hidden
devastating his keep it play I'm really
taco Falls a lot better basketball
player was given a lot more to clean the
inside the policy how he is in the post
taco fall that he will fall perfect so
far and the perfect attraction here in
Vegas love it and throw it up to the
basket there you go there you
Rosi Kowski could only stand there and
wait for the applause the two-time SEC
Player of the Year grant Williams that
comes up short backups Tremont waters
here's the LOB de fair
[Applause]